but was there that part of you because i
know there was that part of me for a
while where i played lex luthor and i
wanted like people to go i'm not i'm not
just lex luthor i'm not just a villain i
i could do comedy
look at me i'm a monkey i could do
anything
do you think that there's a part of like
you know i was never long but him that
was a character i'm different now i'm
i'm
and you know obviously you're handsome
as you look completely different
you wore a fat suit you you changed
you they added teeth on you as neville
but do you ever as a part of you that
just wants to go
i want people to see how great i can
be and i'm not just
this character who was great i think
absolutely
like up until relatively recently that
would have absolutely
been a thing and i still
i still to a degree get a bit frustrated
sometimes when people sort of say
oh he's he like for example i mean i'm
doing this show at the minute it's on
pbs
um and like a lot of the headlines have
been
oh he's no longer never long bottom
anymore and it's like
i haven't been that for 10 years and i
have done things that have been so
wildly different like
i've been in dramas that have won baftas
and i've done all this kind of stuff and
i'm not bragging it's just like i've
done all this stuff
and and yet still 10 years later it's
people's
are making the claim that i've sort of
jumped from harry potter into this and
they've completely
ignored the right the journey that it's
taken to get there
and and that's that i guess can be
frustrating um
because it feels like not that i'm
frustrated by anything to do with harry
potter but it feels like
you have that little voice in your head
that goes hey you know all that hard
work you did for the last 10 years
no one saw it no one cares all
right they're still like
it's like they still think this is the
first job you've done since harry potter
remember that performance
no one watched it right and it's like
that's not true right but it's like that
little thing creeps in
but on the flip side of it i have been
doing a very good job lately and i don't
know if it comes from maturity or
age you know whatever i've done a very
good job of that i've
i've got to a point where i'm i'm
relatively comfortable in life
i'm happily married um and
i'm pretty content with you know current
situation of pandemic aside i'm pretty
content with my lot and it's like
i have been in great films and great
shows and i've been very privileged and
fortunate for that
i kind of just want to work for myself
now good and it's like
if i do a role and and someone
doesn't like it or didn't like didn't
think that it worked because they could
only see me as harry p
has never long bottom or all this thing
i'm like i don't give a because
when i was filming that for three months
i had the best three months of my life
and i got paid and i don't care well
listen to this